ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen euch
allen zu einem ja frühen Stream an dem
wir ganz aktuell in die USA schauen
wollen denn in Iowa sind die
Republikaner in die Präsidentschaftswahl
sozusagen gestartet mit den Vorwahlen
und der zentralen Frage wer denn der
Spitzenkandidat oder der die
Spitzenkandidatin der Republikaner
werden soll und vor allem einer steht da
im Fokus Donald Trump er wurde im
Vorfeld bereits in Iowa als der große
Favorit gehandelt und nach ersten
Ergebnissen und Erkenntnissen aus der
Nacht wird er dieser Rolle wohl gerecht
denn mit großem Abstand hat er diese
erste Vorwahl für sich entschieden einen
Überblick fasst uns Elma Tissen
zusammen sie taten es mit Tüten Papier
oder
Plastik mit
popcornbechern ja sogar mit
klingelbeuteln so geht Demokratie bei
den Republikanern in Iowa angeleitet von
Jennifer Turner in der New Hope church n
die moin hier ist alles Handarbeit in
diesem Fall mit einem ungewöhnlichen
Ergebnis Ron desanttis V dahinter Trump
dann Haley es wäre Jennifer sehr recht
gewesen ich bin ein desantis Fan aber
ich habe mich neutral zurückgehalten bin
aber glücklich mit dem
Ergebnis doch niemand kann ihn hier
schlagen Donald Trump erhält rund 51%
der Stimmen und kündigt dann den
Durchmarsch
an das war nur der Anfang denn die große
Nacht wird im November sein wenn wir uns
unser Land zurückholen und es dann
wirklich wieder großartig
machen Floridas Gouverneur Ron des
Santis ist mit rund
21% abgeschlagener zweiter er will im
Rennen bleiben genau wie Nicki haey sie
verpasst als dritte knapp hinter
desanttis die großeüber chung aber gibt
sich dennoch
kämpferisch wollt ihr mehr vom
Gleichen nein rufen Sie oder wollt ihr
eine neue Generation von konservativen
Anführern dann macht sie sich auf wie
die anderen nach New Hampshire für die
zweite Runde nächste
Woche tja also in Iowa hat es Trump
geschafft mit großem Abstand diese erste
Vorwahl für sich zu entscheiden gelingt
es ihm jetzt gänzlich spit Kandidat der
Republikaner zu werden und erneut ins
Weiße Haus durchzumarschieren das wollen
wir heute bei ZDF heute live Fragen
gerne auch wieder mit euren Meinungen
und Fragen und Kommentaren die ihr uns
jederzeit gerne schicken könnt über die
Kommentarspalten oder auch via Mail und
darüber wollen wir gleich auch noch
reden mit Andrea römmele unserem
heutigen Gast sie ist
Politikwissenschaftlerin zunächst wollen
wir aber in die USA direkt schalten Elm
tevisson hat die Vorwahl in Iowa für uns
mitverfolgt und ist netterweise wach
geblieben für für uns einen schönen
guten Morgen oder guten Abend zu dir
Elma m es ist nun das eingetreten was
viele vermutet hatten Prognosen
angekündigt haben Trump hat diese erste
Vorwahl für sich entschieden wirklich
überraschend kam das ja jetzt nicht
oder Nein Überraschung war es eigentlich
nicht aber er hatte natürlich auf
absolute Dominanz gesetzt das heißt er
hatte eigentlich gehofft hier 53 54 55%
einzufahren nun waren es dann doch ein
paar Prozentpunkte weniger aber das er
eben über 50% liegt das reicht aus um zu
reklamieren für sich dass er
alternativlos ist in der
republikanischen Partei und es sieht
auch sehr viel danach aus er hat diese
Partei gewissermaßen fest im Griff das
zeigt allein der Fakt dass
die Gouverneurin von Iowa sich
eigentlich ja hinter Ron de santtis den
Zweitplatzierten gestellt hatte aber
trotzdem Donald Trump in der Lage war in
diesem Bundesstaat ind dem die
Gouverneurin eigentlich auch sehr
beliebt ist es trotzdem zu schaffen
soweit vor des Santes zu liegen 30%
Punkte und das Nicki Haley den Platz 3
gemacht hat statt Platz 2 das sah in den
letzten Tagen ein bisschen anders aus
den Umfragen wenn Sie hier den zweiten
Platz geschafft hätte dann hätte sich so
eine Art Momentum auch entwickeln können
für sie dann wäre des Sand ist
vielleicht sogar ganz aus dem Rennen
ausgeschieden ja Iowa ist ja ein
agrarstad und du hast die Zahlen gerade
eben angesprochen wir können uns die mal
ganz aktuell anschauen bei uns auf
heute.de da haben wir sie sozusagen mal
schön über sichtlich Donald Trump hier
also mit
51,1% weit vorne Ron de Santes ist
überraschend zweiter du hast es auch
gerade schon gesagt mit
21,2% und ja knapp dahinter Nicki Haley
von der ja die meisten eigentlich
vermutet hatten dass sie Platz 2 nun
machen würde dem ist aber nicht so
welche Bedeutung hat denn dieser auftagt
jetzt gerade speziell für Donald
Trump ja traditionell ist es eigentlich
so dass Iowa immer dazu dient zu
entscheiden wer fliegt raus aus dem
Rennen das ist einem schon mal wieder
fahren wie wegramaswami ist so deutlich
abgeschlagen gewesen im Grunde genommen
eine kleine Version von Donald Trump
aber eben eine jüngere Version genauso
Hardliner wie Donald Trump selber ist ja
mit ein paar Prozentpunkten
ausgeschieden aber man hatte eben
gedacht das hätte auch Ron de Santes
passieren können er hat sich extra viel
Mühe gegeben in Iowa er war in allen 99
Landkreisen in diesem Bundesstaat
unterwegs und wenn er nichts weiter
geworden wäre dann hätte er mit höchster
Wahrscheinlichkeit eben aus dem Rennen
aussteigen müssen weil nächste Woche nu
hampcher ansteht und in New Hampshire
könnte es passieren dass Nicki Haley
vielleicht es sogar schafft Donald Trump
zu schlagen das wäre ein ich sag mal
fast ein Wunder sie liegt aber in den
Umfragen schon relativ nah dran an
Donald Trump also die bleiben nun im
Rennen Nicki Haley und Ron desantis
deshalb bleibt es spannend aber man kann
natürlich doch sehen dass die
überwältigende Mehrheit der Menschen
gerade in eineem bundesstad der sehr
ländlich geprägt ist eben hinter Donald
Trump steht weil sie von ihm glauben
dass er in den vier Jahren in den er im
Amt war eigentlich noch nicht das alles
hat umsetzen können was er für sie hätte
tun können sie nehmen ihm das ab und
deswegen haben sie ihn jetzt hier
unterstützt das bedeutet unterm Strich
dass Donald Trump im Sommer beim
Parteitag der Republikaner in Wisconsin
in Milwaukee dann aus dem Bundesstaat
Iowa 20 der insgesamt 40 Delegierten
Stimmen bekommt die anderen Stimmen
stehen zunächst mal für die anderen
Kandidaten und es ist für ihn ein guter
Einstieg von da aus kann er selbst wenn
er in neuhemscher nicht so gut
abschneidet danach in den anderen
Bundesstaaten seinen Vorsprung noch
deutlich ausbauen ja für alle
Beteiligten ist das ein wahrer
abstimmungsmarathon der da in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten
vorliegt
wie das genau funktioniert in den USA
das fasst uns Antoine kurschelgen mal
zusammen wer Präsidentschaftskandidat
der beiden großen Parteien werden will
muss sich in internen Vorwahlen
durchsetzen in den meisten Bundesstaaten
sind das Primaries sie werden vom Staat
bezahlt und organisiert es sind geheime
Wahlen in einigen Staaten gibt es
sogenannte corkuses sie werden von den
Parteien organisiert und bezahlt gewählt
wird auf kommunalen Veranstaltungen
meist in offenen Abstimmungen bei den
Vorwahlen werden Delegierte für die
Parteitage bestimmt die Staaten mit mehr
Einwohnern bekommen dabei mehr Stimmen
die ersten Abstimmungen gelten als
Stimmungstest die Republikaner beginnen
am 15 Januar in Iowa die Demokraten am
23 Januar in New Hampshire am 5 märz ist
Super Tuesday dann wird in vielen
Bundesstaaten gleichzeitig abgestimmt
die letzten Vorwahlen finden am 4 Juni
statt auf den nominierungsparteitagen
der Republikaner im Juli und der
Demokraten im August werden dann die die
Präsidentschaftskandidaten offiziell
gekürt t em du hast es gerade auch schon
angesprochen die nächste Vorwahl findet
dann am 23 Januar in New Hampshire statt
und Trumps Mitbewerberin Nicki haey
erhofft sich da ein paar gute Chancen
gibt's den allgemein in diesem ganzen
Prozedere Chancen dass einer der
Konkurrenten an Trump vorbeiziehen
könnte also die Chance ist extrem gering
aber wenn er z.B n hemch verlieren würde
gegen Nicki Haley dann wird auch einmal
sichtbar dass Donald Trump auch
verwundbar wäre dass möglicherweise es
eine Alternative geben könnte und das
spannende dabei ist wenn man die
Umfragen sich mal anschaut landesweit
wie viele Menschen im in den USA sagen
wenn Donald Trump in den nächsten
Monaten doch in einem Prozess verurteilt
würde ob sie dann weiter hinter ihm
stehen und da sagt eine Mehrheit auch
unter innerhalb der republikanischen
Partei nein dann wären Sie bereit von
ihm abzurücken und wenn man sich dann
anschaut wie es in einem direkten
Vergleich in den Umfragen momentan
aussieht zwischen Donald Trump und Joe
Biden da würde Donald Trump beiden ganz
knapp schlagen bei der
Präsidentschaftswahl im November hieße
aber die Kandidatin der Republikaner
dann am Ende Nicki haey dann hätte Nicki
haey sogar einen deutlichen Vorsprung
vor vor Joe Biden wenn Sie die
Präsidentschaftskandidatin der
republikanischen Partei wäre und genau
das will Nicki Haley die ehemalige
Gouverneurin von South Carolina
ehemalige UN-Botschafterin hat für
Donald Trump gearbeitet die will das in
den nächsten Tagen auch vor nem schon
noch mal sehr klar machen wenn man auf
sie setzen würde dann hätten die
Republikaner durch den
Generationswechsel durch eine Frau die
antritt große Chancen Joe Biden zu
schlagen weil sie eben auch mit weniger
Drama Antritt als Donald Trump aber noch
mal es ist sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich
dass Nicki Haley das schafft denn Donald
Trump scheint eben diese republikanische
Partei doch sehr fest im Griff zu haben
tja und das trotz juristischer Verfahren
die du gerade schon angesprochen hast
vor allem die Rolle Trumps bei der
Erstürmung des amerikanischen Kapitols
hingt da noch sehr nach vom 6 Januar
ähm da stehen ja noch große
weitreichende ähm Entscheidungen der
Gerichte aus wie sehr kann ihm das
vielleicht noch auf die Füße fallen in
diesem ganzen
vorwahlprozess das kann passieren es
gibt ja vier Strafverfahren insgesamt
die anhängig sind da geht es eben unter
anderem um diesen Sturm aufs Kapitol und
es äh landen in den nächsten Wochen
möglicherweise Verfahren vor dem
Obersten Gerichtshof schon eins dass es
sicher wird da landen oder ist da
gelandet das ist die Frage ob Donald
Trump auf dem Wahlzettel stehen darf im
Bundesstaat Colorado da will der Oberste
Gerichtshof am 8 februar eine
öffentliche Anhörung machen wir rechnen
damit dass bis zum Ende des Monats
Februar der Gerichtshof dann auch
entscheiden wird ob Donald Trump auf
diesem Wahlzettel auftauchen darf das
Oberste Gericht in Colorado hat nämlich
gesagt weil Donald Trump in ein einem
Aufstand beteiligt gewesen ist darf er
nach einem bestimmten nach einer
bestimmten Regel in der amerikanischen
Verfassung im 14 Verfassungszusatz
Verfassungszusatz eben nicht mehr
antreten für die Wahl zum Präsidenten
wenn der oberste gerichtshshof dem statt
geben würde dann wäre Donald Trump
eigentlich raus ähm wir rechnen nicht
unbedingt damit dass der Oberste
Gerichtshof das tut aber das ist ein
Verfahren das ist extrem wichtig und
könnte natürlich in dieser Wahl alles
verändern und das andere ist die große
Frage ob Donald Trump immun ist als
Präsident wenn tatsächlich noch während
seiner Amtszeit nämlich eben am 6 Januar
2021 er tatsächlich diesen Aufstand
aufgestachelt hat wofür es eine Menge
Belege gibt dann wäre er vielleicht weil
er zu dem Zeitpunkt Präsident war eben
durch Immunität geschützt dieses
Verfahren liegt momentan beim
Berufungsgericht in Washington DC wenn
Trump da verliert dann geht er mit
Sicherheit vor den Obersten Gerichtshof
und dann müssten die obersten gerichter
eben auch darüber entscheiden also es
sind eine Reihe von Verfahren im Gange
die Donald Trump in den nächsten Wochen
mindestens mal noch eine Menge
Schwierigkeiten machen könnten
möglicherweise wenn es zu einer
Verurteilung oder auch von einem
Ausschluss von den Wahlen zu einem
Ausschluss von den Wahlen käme dann wäre
es für Donald Trump natürlich extrem
schwierig tja gelingt der Durchmarsch
ins Weiße Haus von Trump oder er nicht
weil dann doch
juristische Probleme dazwischen
gretschen danke schön Elm bis hier hin
wir wollen gleich noch weiter reden
wollen aber zuvor nach Los Angeles
schalten dort sitzt Andrea römele sie
ist Politikwissenschaftlerin und aktuell
Thomas manfellow und bered zu dem
Politiker und Parteien nicht nur in
Deutschland sondern spannenderweise auch
weltweit so unter anderem war sie beim
Wahlkampf von Hillary Clinton auch mit
involviert schönen guten Abend nach Los
Angeles zu Ihnen Frau
röel ja guten Morgen nach Mainz ja die
Zeitverschiebung wir haben gerade schon
gesehen und gehört Trump also hat in
Iowa das geschafft sich da klar
abzusetzen und als Gewinner rauszugehen
die Anhängerschaft hält nach wie vor zu
ihm trotz juristischer Verfahren warum
ist das eigentlich
so man darf jetzt nicht vergessen dass
Iowa Herr tevisson hat's ja gerade auch
ausgeführt ein besonderes Bundesland ist
ist ein Bundesland das stark von der
Landwirtschaft geprägt ist das zu über
90% auch weiß ist darf man auch nicht
vergessen und für die Menschen dort dort
spielt Loyalität eine ganz zentrale
Rolle ähm die Frage ob ein Kandidat dann
Joe Biden schlagen kann ist etwas was in
Iowa die Wählerinnen und Wähler nur mit
14 % angegeben haben also nur 14% sahen
das als ein wichtiges Kriterium äh äh
bei Ihrer Wahl das ist landesweit anders
da ähm ist das deutlich mehr und auf
genau auf diesen Punkt will ja auch
Nicki haey setzen ja uns erreichen schon
die ersten Fragen und Kommentare auf
Facebook und Youtube NY one schreibt z.B
auf Youtube so eine ja allgemeine
Stimmung von ihm also muss man in
Amerika scheinbar unterhaltsam sein und
populistische Parolen von sich geben um
gewählt zu werden ist das Trumps
Strategie oder setzt er tatsächlich auch
auf Themen die er dann anspricht die die
Menschen dann in Amerika auch ansprechen
er setzt auf Themen ganz klar also make
America great again er setzt auf
Deportation er setzt
natürlich auch auf die economie klar
aber er er kommuniziert das auf eine
sehr populistische Art und Weise sehr
emotional das kommt bei den Wählern an
und interessanterweise ist er ein
Kandidat der gleich drei Rollen auf
einmal in diesem Wahlkampf hatte er hat
hat sich als Amtsinhaber präsentiert
also als ehemaliger Präsident er war ist
aber Herausforderer auch so hat er sich
präsentiert aber auch als großes Opfer
als
Opfer der Justiz
als jemanden dem die Wahl gestohlen
wurde und das ist auch etwas was aus
unserer Perspektive ganz erstaunlich
aber das ist etwas was viele Menschen in
Iowa auch geglaubt haben mm also kann ih
jetzt eigentlich auch gar nichts mehr
schaden wenn tatsächlich jetzt
juristische Konsequenzen drohen sollten
nimmt er die Opferrolle ein und Amerika
glaubt's
ihm na das ganz so abwarten also Iowa
ist immer der Anfang der
präsidentschafts
des
Präsidentschaftswahlkampfes da wird das
Wahljahr eingeläutet aber es sind noch
sehr viele Bundesstaaten vor ihm die
anders auch von der Demografie
zusammengesetzt äh sin in denen sehr
viel mehr Latinos Hispanics
afroamericans wohnen die anders wählen
bei denen eben auch die die Frage ist
kann dieser Kandidat den wir wählen den
republikanischen Kandidaten den wählen
wie groß sind seine Chancen dann den
Präsidenten den amtierenden Präsidenten
Joe Biden zu schlagen das in den anderen
Bundesländern ist es schon eine ganz
wichtige Frage und es ist noch nicht
klar
wie diese ganzen Gerichtsprozesse dann
letztendlich wie die Urteile ausfallen
werden und wie diese Gerichtsprozesse
auch auf die Stimmung und auf die
Loyalität der Bevölkerung abferben in
Iowa war es so dass der der gerichtsah
letztendlich auch ein wahlkampfort war
das ist in der in der Iowa
Wahlkampfstrategie gut aufgegangen ob es
landesweit gut aufgehen wird werden wir
sehen mhm aus strategischer Sicht wenn
das jetzt doch drohen sollte ihm auf die
Füße zu fallen was könnte Trump dann
eigentlich dann nur noch machen oder was
sollte er tun um sich dann noch über
Wasser zu halten na gut also wenn der
Supreme Court ähm ihm wirklich nach ihn
wirklich nach Artikel 14 verurteilt und
er nicht zur Wahl antreten kanner kein
Kandidat mehr äh äh sein kann für die
Präsidentschaftswahl dann muss die
Republik ische Partei einen anderen
Kandidaten ins renn schicken aber das
wird zu massiven massiv sten Unruhen
hier im Land führen wir wissen der
Supreme Court ist sehr konservativ
besetzt in der Präsidentschaft Donald
Trumps von 2016 bis 2020 ist es Donald
Donald hatte Donald Trump die
Möglichkeit drei Posten zu besetzen
das ist viel von diesen neuen
Richterinnen und Richtern die da sind
man hört schon dass der Supreme Court
sagt wenn wir hier ein Urteil fällen
dann muss es ein Urteil sein das relativ
einstimmig ist also mindestens 7:2
Stimmen um hier ähm
äh irgendwie Klarheit zu schaffen und
vielen schwebt eben die es damals
miterlebt haben noch die buschgor ähm
der buschgor Wahlkampf vor der ja dann
2000 auch vor dem Supreme Court landete
das zu massiven Unruhen auch im Land
geführt hat und das versucht man zu
vermeiden ob es sich vermeiden lässt
dass werden wir sehen es entwickelt sich
gerade mit völlig offenem Ausgang es ist
dann eigentlich aus strategischer Sicht
klug wie jetzt Donald Trump das alles zu
hinterfragen gerade wenn er dann belangt
wird und anzuzweifeln was so staatliche
Organe dann
entscheiden ja also Donald Trump fährt
aus seiner Perspektive eine sehr kluge
Strategie er wirft jetzt alles nach
vorne versucht Fakten zu schaffen und
auch hier waren diese 50% also dass er
heute über
50% gekommen ist war wichtig für sein
narrativ weil je mehr Unterstützung er
hinter sich versammelt desto schwerer
wird es letztendlich auch sein ihn vom
Ballet also ihm vom wahzettel abzuhalten
mm zuletzt Fr rmele stelle ich auch
ihnen die Frage wie die nächsten Wochen
und Monate bei den Vorwahlen der
Republikaner laufen werden unser
Zuschauer Peter Dominik schreibt viel
Landbevölkerung viel Trump sie haben
auch schon angesprochen in anderen
Staaten könnte es vielleicht anders
aussehen Nicki haly rechnet sicher in
manch anderen Staaten größere Chancen
aus
Emma tibison sagt es ist jar
unwahrscheinlich unterschreiben Sie das
oder sehen Sie es
anders ich sehe es ein bisschen anders
ich glaube die ganz große Frage wird
sein bleibt die santtis im Rennen für
die santtis war Iowa der Grundstock
seiner Kampagne er hat unheimlich viel
Arbeit in diese Kampagne reingesteckt er
hat auch was die Wahlkämpferinnen und
Wahlkämpfer anbelangt das Land
sensationell abgedeckt unheimlich viel
canvassing also an den Häusern klopfen
und so weiter betrieben und ist dann
letztendlich im Vergleich zu Trump doch
sehr sehr abgeschlagen und doch auch nah
an Nick haey dran auch wenn er jetzt die
Nase vorne hat und die anderen Staaten
werden für ihn schwieriger sein als für
Nicki Haley aus Trumps Perspektive hätte
nichts besseres passieren können als
zwei Kandidaten die so nah beieinander
sind weil jetzt erstmal keiner rausgeht
und Trump nur dann gestellt werden kann
oder wir haben nur dann eine Chance
einen anderen republikanischen
Kandidaten zu sehen als Donald Trump
wenn wir nur einen Gegner oder eine
Gegnerin haben wenn Trump zwei Gegner
hat hat er ein noch leichteres Spiel und
das ist jetzt so die Frage ob nicht doch
die Santes sich aus dem Rennen rauszieht
aber das werden die nächsten Tage
ergeben ich würde sagen dass die
ernsthafteste Gegnerin für Donald Trump
nicki haey ist und Nicki haey und das
wird auch ihr narrativ sein jetzt in
ihren Kampagnen dass den Umfragen
zufolge sie eine sehr viel bessere
Chance hat Joe Biden zu schlagen als
Donald Trump Einschätzungen von der
Politikwissenschaftlerin Andrea römmele
ich danke Ihnen für die Zeit und ja
Grüße nach Los Angeles und an dieser
Stelle noch der Hinweis an euch ihr
könnt gerne weiterhin Fragen stellen
wiea Mail oder die kommentarspealten
denn nach diesem Stream werden wir noch
live gehen auf insta live und weiterhin
auch mit Frau römele dazu reden und
gerne reiche ich dann eure Fragen an Sie
weiter jetzt aber zurück nach die Moen
in Iowa da steht unser Kollege Elma
tevison Elma wir haben eine
Zuschauerfrage bekommen von dem User
wilgar Ron der sich fragt was würde denn
passieren wenn Trump diesen Durchmarsch
ins Weiße Haus erneut schaffen würde
Stichwort auch ukraineepitik was würde
das bedeuten werden die Republikaner und
Trump beim nein für die ukrainehilfen
bleiben ja es sieht alles danach aus
dass sich alles verändern wird wenn
Donald hab es tatsächlich ins Weiße Haus
schafft weil anders als im Jahr 2016 als
er für viele jah überraschend ins Amt
kam steht er da nicht alleine relativ
ohne Plan mit einer Menge versprechen
die er gemacht hat sondern diesmal gibt
es ein großes Netzwerk von
rechtskonservativen in den USA die ihn
massiv unterstützen die haben so eine
Art Masterplan entworfen was sie in den
verschiedenen Themenbereichen mit ihm
zusammen in den ersten 100 Tagen
eigentlich alles umsetzen wollen das
nennt sich Projekt 2015 2 und in diesem
Plan stehen einige Dinge drin die
Amerika
eigentlich zum Nachdenken bringen
sollten man sieht eigentlich da dass man
es auf ein eher autoritäreres System
anlegt dass Donald Trump ein Präsident
sein würde der nicht nur sagt was er
will sondern das dann auch eben
entsprechend umgesetzt wird unter
anderem indem man 50.000 Mitarbeiter der
Regierung entfernt aus ihren Ämtern bzw
aus ihren Jobs das sind ja keine wahläm
sonder aus ihren Jobs und sie ersetzt
durch Gesinnungsgenossen von Donald
Trump der wird momentan auch eifrig
rekrutiert quer durch das Land man
versucht Menschen zu finden die bereit
sind ihm gewissermaßen zu dienen und das
umzusetzen was er sagt da gibt es
regelrechte gesinnungstest die da
abgefragt werden und wenn man das machen
kann dann könnte Donald Trump ein
Präsident sein der Anweisungen gibt der
die Ministerien auch ganz nach seinem
Sinn umbaut und als Werkzeuge einsetzt
z.B gegen politisch anders das denkende
auch das steht in diesen Konzepten drin
also dass das Justizministerium
beispielsweise genutzt werden kann gegen
jede Art von Opposition dass aber auch
eher z.B die Ministerien nutzen wird
nicht nur um die Grenze dicht zu machen
zu Mexiko hin sondern eben auch
Deportation
Massendeportation durchzuführen
Internierungslager einzurichten und
ähnliches das hat er auch hier im
Wahlkampf sehr offen und klar
versprochen er hat Sätze gesagt wie das
zuwand die illegalen Zuwanderer hat er
gesagt das Blut Amerikas vergiften das
ist im Grunde genommen eine Rhetorik wie
man sie sonst nur aus faschistischen
Systemen des letzten Jahrhunderts kennt
aber das kam bei den Menschen sehr gut
an wir haben hier im Land bei unserer
Reise erlebt dass sehr viele gesagt
haben Thema Nummer 1 Schließung der
Grenzen weil man Angst hat vor denen die
da kommen zum zweiten die Wirtschaft
Inflation die Preissteigerungen die zwar
deutlich zurückgegangen sind aber immer
noch vorhanden sind das merken die
Menschen das waren die Hauptthemen und
Donald Trump schürt diese Angst weil er
sagt dass der Amtsinhaber Joe Biden
einer ist der nicht mehr Herr seiner
Sinne ist dass er eigentlich dieses Land
im Grunde genommen anderen Preis gibt
auch das ist geglaubt worden von den
Menschen hier obwohl das muss man einmal
klar sagen die Wirtschaftsdaten für die
USA momentan ziemlich gut aussehen 4,9%
Wachstum der Durchschnittslohn ist auch
gestiegen über das Niveau der vor der
Pandemie von vor einigen Jahren und Joe
beiden das erleben wir ja ist geistig
Herr seiner Sinne und voll in der Lage
das Amt auszuüben aber er wirkt
unglaublich gebrechlich und wenn diese
Bilder im Fernsehen zu sehen sind dann
glauben viele Menschen das was Donald
Trump behauptet nämlich dass ein starker
Führer in diesem Land gebraucht wird mhm
das ist auch noch ein gutes Stichwort
die Republikaner die die Demokraten
starten ja ebenfalls mit ihren Vorwahlen
ähnlich wie die Republikaner m aber
wobei bei denen der Wahlausgang ja schon
klar ist dass Joe Biden da als
Spitzenkandidat rausgehen wird warum ist
das eigentlich so warum finden die
Demokraten keine Alternative zu Joe
Biden ja das haben wir uns mal vom
linken Flügel der Partei erklären lassen
vor ein paar Wochen bei einem
Hintergrundgespräch da kann ich nicht
sagen mit wem wir geredet haben aber es
waren wichtige Leute eben aus diesem
linken Flügel der Demokratischen Partei
und die sagten sie sind hoch zufrieden
mit Joe Biden er ist der Präsident von
dem sie vorher nicht gedacht hätten dass
er so viel von ihrer Agenda umsetzt
beispielsweise in der Sozialpolitik in
der Zuwanderungspolitik in vielen Fragen
und sie sind damit so zufrieden dass sie
sagen den unterstützen wir weiter auch
wenn er alt ist auch wenn man sich
wünschen würde dass er an eine jüngere
Generation übergibt aber weil man so
erfolgreich war aus ihrer Sicht ist es
selbstverständlich für Sie dass dieser
Mann auch wieder antritt weil man in der
nächsten Amtszeit wenn er denn gewinnen
würde weitere Vorhaben umsetzen kann
jedenfalls setzt der linke Flügel der
Partei momentan noch da drauf äh ob
diese Unterstützung für Joe Biden
erhalten bleibt das wird man über die
nächsten Wochen verfolgen können eben
bei diesen Vorwahlen South Carolina ist
glaube ich der wichtigste startaat in
den nächsten Wochen Anfang Februar wenn
da in South Carolina am 3 februar über
den Kandidaten der Demokraten
entschieden wird er hat nicht viel
Konkurrenz da sind ein zwei aber die
liegen weit weit hinter ihm aber es wird
drauf ankommen wie viele Menschen gehen
dann wirklich wählen an diesem Tag und
signalisieren damit dass sie eben
tatsächlich hinter diesem doch recht
alten Präsidenten stehen der aber aus
ihrer Sicht tatsächlich einiges in den
letzten drei Jahren vier Jahren fast
geliefert hat schauen wir zum Abschluss
noch mal ganz kurz auf Trump Elmer
unsere Zuschauer interessiert vor allem
das ganze
juristische um Trump Matthias fragt wie
realistisch ist es dass Trump noch
gerichtlich gestoppt werden kann es ist
ja eine Möglichkeit dass er aus den
Vorwahlen doch noch mal
ausscheidet juristisch bedingt wie wie
siehst du
das
also bei der Frage ob er auf dem
Wahlzettel stehen kann kann der Oberste
Gerichtshof theoretisch ihn aus dem
Rennen werfen bis Ende Februar ich halte
das für unwahrscheinlich aber die
anderen Verfahren da setzt Donald Trump
auf Verzögerungstaktik er versucht dass
die letzten Entscheidungen darüber eben
irgendwann nach der Wahl liegen bis
dahin könnte er vielleicht ins Amt
gekommen sein und dann wäre in der Tat
es so dass er sich dann selber
begnadigen könnte oder auch wieder immun
wäre gegen diese Verfahren das ist seine
Strategie es ist nicht ausgeschlossen
dass es vorher schon zu einem Urteil
oder mehreren Urteilen kommt wenn das so
ist könnte er weiter Wahlkampf machen er
könnte ja sogar wenn er verurteilt wäre
aus dem Gefängnis heraus diesen
Wahlkampf machen und gewählt werden aber
wir wissen eben aus Umfragen dass doch
sehr viele auch innerhalb der
republikanischen Partei denken wenn es
ein Urteil gegen Donald Trump gibt dann
ist er eigentlich nicht mehr der
richtige Kandidat um am Ende als
Präsident dieses Land zu führen wenn wir
noch mal auf das schauen was 2021 rings
ums Kapitol
passiert ist könnte das im schlimmsten
Fall auch noch mal drohen wenn Donald
Trump tatsächlich verurteilt
würde oh das hat Frau römmel ja vorhin
auch sehr eindrucksvoll gesagt ich
glaube das kann schon viel eher drohen
wenn der Oberste Gerichtshof
beispielsweise entscheidet dass er nicht
auf dem Stimmzettel stehen dürfte in
einigen Bundesstaaten schon dann droht
Gewalt in diesem Land wir hatten in den
letzten Wochen tatsächlich eine Reihe
von Vorfällen wo Pläne auf flogen sind
wo es aber auch Drohungen gab und
Einschüchterungsversuche gegen
z.B Richter gegen Wahlbeamte in einigen
Bundesstaaten gegen politisch anders
denken ne in den USA gibt es das was man
swatting nennt das heißt man ruft
einfach das Einsatzkommando der Polizei
und behauptet da wäre ein Verbrechen
gerade im Gange und das macht man und
gibt die Adresse z.B der Richterin an
die in Washington über eines der
Verfahren präsidieren wird gegen Donald
Trump und dann kommt eben solcher ein
Einsatzkommando in in so einer
extremituation kann dann theoretisch
alles passieren es kann ganz schnell
eskalieren obwohl da eigentlich gar
nichts gewesen ist solche Vorfälle gibt
es und das signalisiert viele die große
Sorgen haben dass hier eine
Gewaltbereitschaft vorhanden ist wird
durch Umfragen gedeckt in den USA gibt
es etwa 8% der Bevölkerung die im
Grundsatz bereit sind Gewalt als
politisches Mittel zu rechtfertigen das
sind nicht nur Republikaner da gibt es
auch im Extrem linken Bereich einige
aber das hab das umrecht über 20
Millionen Menschen die im Grundsatz
bereit wären dann auch Gewalt anzuwenden
das werden also noch spannende Monate in
den USA bis zum November wenn die
Präsidentschaftswahlen anstehen
Einschätzungen live aus Iowa von Elma
tevisson vielen Dank zu dir
Elma ja und damit sind wir am Ende bei
ZDF heute live wir melden uns gleich
wieder bei Instagram mit einem
instaalive und freuen uns dort ebenfalls
auf all eure Fragen bis dahin tschüss
und bis bald